the world we live in now it's highly
digital place but that wasn't always the
case until four years ago so if we
rewind letting people know about your
products was a little harder than so
even if you go back say five or ten
years promoting your products wasn't as
easy as it is today I mean people had to
resort to you know good old-fashioned
newspapers putting in an ad or those big
thick books called the Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then fax fax
ads I'm commonly known way to advertise
by the way who has faxes now but people
did advertise via fax just a few decades
ago so these were all the ways in which
people had to get their product and
service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man I'm glad
I'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service and engage in
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that
million-dollar question
and what's that million dollar question
it's how can you rise above the rest and
so today's session is
to be how to start with social media
marketing so you can rise above the rest
leveraging this great platform that we
all take advantage of today so let's
start by asking the question what is
social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals so you can create
various forms of content for different
social media platforms so that's really
in a nutshell with social media
marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
and what we mean by viral is spreading
like wildfire
one user sending it to another as
rapidly as can be and before you know it
you get you know millions of views and
millions of likes I mean that's the
power of social media marketing so why
do we want to do social media marketing
and I think we just answered some of
those questions but let's dig a little
bit deeper we mentioned in our
definition of social media marketing
that we have the opportunity to really
build our brand awareness and that is no
more truthful than with social media
marketing more so than any other digital
marketing channel social media marketing
allows us to really put our brand in a
good light in a good position in front
of the right eyeballs so it allows us to
really improve our brand by pushing out
the appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right
balls and we are building a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see it every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase we can certainly leverage
social media marketing for SEO for
search engine rankings
it's about off page SEO it's about
posting content on social media
platforms to build up some linkjuice ok
so there is some inherent benefits to
working SEO and social media side by
side it's cost-effective well if you're
posting content on Twitter or Facebook
it doesn't cost you anything it just
takes a little bit of time and
creativity now if you want to go ahead
and do some advertising on these
platforms yes it's gonna cost you but
you'd be surprised not going to be as
costly as say other search platforms
like say Google or Bing where you're
actually paying for keywords and pain
per click for those keywords so social
media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increased top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to getting
to know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product and service and then continuing
to buy that product or service I mean
that's increasing the top funnel traffic
and not just the traffic but the
conversions so at every step in the
process social media allows you to build
that funnel depending on where somebody
is whether they're seeing your brand for
the first time or actually returning to
purchase the product or service again so
that's the inherent benefit these are
the inherent benefits of social media
marketing now we talk about social media
marketing what are the channels used for
social media marketing how can we use
them it's really social media marketing
is a channel in itself so let's take a
look at the platform's of
with social media marketing now there
are some really popular platforms so if
you can't tell just by these logos then
you probably have not used social media
marketing or social media platforms
before or taking part in social media at
all but you know one would like to think
that the majority of you users out there
today know at Facebook is what the logo
looks like what it does same with
Instagram which is owned by Facebook
LinkedIn b2b platform its YouTube great
very popular video sharing platform and
then Twitter which is considered micro
blogging but still social media so these
are the most popular popular platforms
out there but there are hundreds of
social media platforms in fact when we
talk about social media marketing and
competing anything from micro blogging
to video sharing like YouTube - b2b
networks like LinkedIn to say
bookmarking sites like stumbled upon
content sharing sites like Reddit Q&A
sites like Korra so there's plenty of
different types of social media
platforms out there in fact if you folks
have any popular or you think valid
social media platforms that these
listeners here should really get to know
and understand and use then go ahead and
put that in the comment section
underneath this video I'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
let there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
Facebook so Facebook has an average of
two point two seven billion monthly
active users now that number is
fluctuating because we're talking about
billions billions billions of monthly
active users and that numbers probably
trending up 88% of all users are on
mobile so what does that tell you that
tells you that
Facebook has an app and the app is very
popular in fact I tend to use the app
more than I use the webpage for Facebook
okay so I don't necessarily log on via
the internet on my laptop I go right to
the app it's just easier easier to
disseminate information easier to add
friends comment respond it cetera so
it's no surprise that 88% of all users
use mobile now sixty-six percent of
mobile monthly users use Facebook daily
so a lot of recurring users going back
on a day to day basis two-thirds so it's
an addiction more than it if anything
else because what Facebook is is really
you're getting information from the
people you trust
care about like work with share a group
with your common interest with partake
in the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions I mean
that's what Facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's gonna be addicting to take part in
them you know the closest network you
can ever get to as your family so if
your family is on Facebook then likely
you're going to be on Facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends I
know in the United States you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so Facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on Facebook so that's what makes
it the addictive part so if you think
about it from an end users perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat you're
thinking hey two-thirds a monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever I'm
targeting has to be on Facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors aged
65 plus or using Facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using facebook so
Facebook is trending older however
thirty five percent of the audience is
below the age of 25
it's not just trending up it's also
trending down so a lot of young people
are still using Facebook and then
Facebook you know it's pretty evenly
matched between males and females now if
I'm either slewing old viewing older or
skewing younger on my target audience
and half female half as male then I know
somewhere in there whoever I'm targeting
is gonna be on Facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on Facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between Facebook has something for
everyone
now Facebook allows for video content so
you could post videos all day long so if
you have YouTube videos you can share
those YouTube videos on Facebook in fact
video just like on most platforms tends
to provide better engagement in the
industries that can really capitalize on
facebook tend to be food and beverage
news and media and e-commerce meaning
you're selling a product Facebook has
you know plugins and that allows you to
really accentuate what you're trying to
sell when I say that accentuate I mean
really incorporate an opportunity for
people to use the Facebook platform to
not only just engage not only to share
but to by taking that process a step
further so if you're selling a product
you can more or less set up a Facebook
shop if you will and sell your product
there so that's why it benefits those
that are in the e-commerce industry
selling a particular product or in the
food and beverage industry now some of
the most liked pages on Facebook spans
across many many brands but let's just
take a look at coca-cola for example and
coca-cola just pretty much pinpoints
everything great about what you could do
on Facebook I mean you could see here
they have their opening page is of it
and so you can see they're posting
different content about you know this is
about a grant how they're helping the
city of Atlanta you know they're talking
about recycling so to me these are
community based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
Facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge fortune 500 company like
coca-cola is not necessarily just using
Facebook just to push ecommerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
facebook taking advantage of everything
Facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness community building your
sharing you know updated information not
only about the company but in this case
coca-cola is situated in Atlanta Georgia
in the United States so you know what
are they doing with the community okay
so this is a good example of course it's
a big example because coca-cola is a big
company that worldwide but the great
thing about Facebook is you can always
take a peek at what other companies are
doing whether you have a million plus
people liking your page or a hundred
plus people like in your page you can
always get ideas as to how they're
leveraging Facebook now if you do have a
company you can create a Facebook page
for your business just like coca-cola so
you want to be able to separate out your
business from your personal page and
like everything you do whether that's
writing a blog or creating a video you
want to have original content that's
relevant to your audience you want to
use Facebook for some promotion but
every post doesn't necessarily need to
be promoting your product or service you
saw what we just witnessed on the
coca-cola page it was about what they
were doing to you know benefit the earth
with recycling or what they're doing in
conjunction with the with the city of
Atlanta so they're more community based
posts and so to me that's original
content positive content that isn't
necessarily pushing their product per se
now you could argue hey it's coca-cola
they have the biggest brand in the world
and that's true but just think about
your product and service think about
your brand if you're trying to build
brand awareness what is your brand stand
for and if your brand stands for say the
globe the ecosystem the environment then
you probably want to be pushing out post
in that direction if that's what you
stand for as a brand then you want
people to know that because like-minded
people are on Facebook and there's
like-minded people are going to be the
ones who like your page who engage with
your content and tell other people about
it so you always want to go regional you
always want to be true to yourself and
true to your brand and then you could
take advantage of user-generated content
like sharing a user's experience of
using your product so in other words if
somebody's engaging with you or they've
posted something about your brand and
product you can reciprocate you can
certainly post something that is similar
to what somebody's doing with your
product or brand so that's a good way to
create some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
Facebook I mean there's lots of things
you can do on Facebook plenty of things
if we float back to coca-cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do I see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling t-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
coca-cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
a ten aids campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you can see they have information about
us they have different events they have
a community link as well and so you can
see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's
which you can do on Facebook you can
post polls you can put your Instagram
feed in there you can add testimonials
so there's a lot you can do on your page
you just got to get creative and take
advantage of everything Facebook has to
offer be true to yourself and before you
know it I mean you're gonna have you
know a number of likes on your business
page as well so some other tips about
Facebook when it comes to content you
want to schedule your content okay you
don't want to just continue to post
back-to-back-to-back-to-back you want to
space your content out and another great
advantage to facebook as i already
mentioned about social media marketing
that's advertising so Facebook owns
Instagram they have a great tool for
communicating called Facebook Messenger
and so you can advertise leveraging
Facebook messages you can leverage
Instagram and what you need to do is if
you go to Facebook's ad manager and you
create a campaign when you go to create
a campaign you're gonna click on
placements and depending on what you're
trying to do let's just say you're
trying to build brand awareness you can
actually hone in on you know Facebook
you could hone in on Instagram you could
do a number of different things within
Facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to carousel see you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience
who are you targeting so remember
Facebook has old young and everybody in
between between men and women and so you
can specifically target interest you can
specifically target gender and age
allocation so Facebook really allows you
to hone in on who your audience is if
you're advertising and so that's the
great thing about Facebook they have a
lot of users and your you have an
opportunity to hone in on a segment of
that user base
now Facebook also has metrics that you
can look at to really understand how
people are interacting with your ads how
people are interacting with your post so
let's take a look at that so if we go to
Facebook
when you go to your page you can click
on insights and you can actually see
some insights on posts that I've been
posted on your page you can get insights
into how many people viewed it how many
people liked it how many people engaged
how many people you reached with your
post can you have information about
videos followers Facebook provides
recommendations so this is all part of
Facebook Insights so if you're posting
on Facebook Facebook will give you
feedback as to how your post to perform
it now if you're running ads on Facebook
you can simply just view metrics related
to how your ads are performing so you
can see how many people clicked on an ad
how many people the ad reached how much
you've spent okay you can look at it by
demographic you can even see cost per
results so you can get a lot of good
insights into how your ads are
performing as well so if you're running
a campaign targeting a specific audience
on Facebook you can look at the you know
stats and metrics surrounding that
campaign and again for your Facebook
page you have Facebook Insights so if
you have any questions you know feel
free we have a video called Facebook
advertising tips and tricks so feel free
to you know take a look at this video on
simply learns YouTube channel for more
information about facebook and if again
if you have any comments to share about
facebook feel free to put them under the
comments section okay let's turn our
attention to one of the platforms
Facebook actually owns Instagram so
Instagram is a place where you can
actually promote your brand product or
service through the power of imagery or
video and so the average number of
monthly users on Instagram reaches 1
billion and 32% of all Internet users
are on Instagram so a lot of users using
it it's very easy platform use you just
the only prerequisite you need your
mobile phone so you open up that app
it's as simple as just uploading
uploading an image that's why Instagram
is so popular because it's just a simple
tool to use
to go ahead and just post an image with
some hashtags so 60% of all Instagram
users are women so unlike Facebook it
does tend to slant more on the female
side and 59% of the audience is a bit
younger between age 18 to 29 so slants
more women and Slim's more younger and
so if these particular demographic and
age groups tend to fit your target
audience then Instagram is a place you
probably want to be for social media
marketing so as a magic content that
works best our photos or videos I would
always slant towards videos if you have
them available but photos
you know the rule of thumb is photos
always tell a thousand words a thousand
stories a thousand interpretations
images are just always the best way to
go as well I mean if you don't have the
videos hey nothing to be sad about if
you fall back on imagery so you can
really put your brand in a good
perspective and a good light by posting
images and as you can imagine if 18 to
29 year old women are on Instagram you
know that's skewing towards a certain
demographic but in terms of industry it
is open to most industries but the ones
that tend to be most successful are
beauty food and beverage and e-commerce
no food beverage always tends to work
well when you have video and imagery
likewise beauty but ecommerce if you're
selling that t-shirt or shoe you know
Instagram allows the platform to work in
a way where people can purchase that
product right within the platform so
that's why it tends to work well with
e-commerce okay there are lots of
channels just like on Facebook lots of
channels on Instagram I mean some of the
most followed brands are Chanel
Starbucks Nike I mean if you have a
product or service that you want to push
out there then Instagram is the way to
go just for brand awareness if you're
selling shoes then why not take images
of and photos of their
and get them posted on this to room like
I said it's very simple to use all you
need some hashtags to go along with that
photo of a shoe or photo of that cup of
coffee and Instagram kind of takes care
of itself
I mean photos do accentuate the product
if you have them
so leverage Instagram if you're really
trying to build up some brand awareness
for a particular product some best
practices here on Instagram is you know
have a compelling bio a good profile
picture you know add a link to a landing
page and you know leverage emojis if you
have to so set yourself up nicely on
Instagram you know if you're in a
particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
brands like coca-cola like Starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
throw some hashtags in there you can see
what other people are hash tagging on
Instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag I'd probably have 2
to 3 hashtags per photo then don't be
afraid to use both photos and videos
videos do tend to work well on pretty
much any platform they tend to work well
on websites and blogs so why not use
them on social media where people can
engage ok so videos and imageries both
work well on Instagram okay you can also
get shoutouts from other influencers you
plenty of influencers on Instagram
especially in beauty especially in food
and beverage fashion tends to be another
industry that has a lot of influencers
so feel free to reach out to them
reciprocate see how you can work
together where they can actually you
know give you a shout-out on your
particular product you want to keep your
Instagram account updated you can update
those with Instagram stories it's
basically you showing off a particular
product you know over a span of a few
seconds or even a minute that's an
Instagram story they're very popular
easy to use you can even run contests to
boost engagement so for example if your
particular product is a particular food
like a hamburger
you know hey post a contest about you
know allowing your followers to post the
best good-looking tasty you know
hamburger as an example or it could be
something else in terms of fashion hey
what's your best outfit on a Friday
night before you go out for the evening
you know there's always things you can
do to spur engagement especially in a
platform like Instagram where people
like to post photos and then I mentioned
this earlier with Facebook Ads you can
run Instagram ads to give a particular
post a boost so if we take a little
snapshot of what we have available in
facebook ads manager you can choose
Instagram as the particular platform so
if you just want to advertise an
Instagram when you go to your placements
you could choose just Instagram either
the feed or the stories so you can
choose one of these two options if you
wanted want to boost your posts get some
more eyeballs on that it's a cost per
click platform so anytime somebody
clicks it's gonna cost you but you know
just like Facebook you know the cost per
click tends to slant a little bit lower
it really depends on what you're trying
to post when you're trying to post it
who else is posting but hey the
Instagram feed and the stories could be
a good option if you're really trying to
draw attention to a particular product
let's turn our attention now to the b2b
platform called LinkedIn LinkedIn is a
very powerful popular
business-to-business platform it has 260
million active users monthly and unlike
Instagram where it Instagram slants more
towards women LinkedIn slants more
towards men 57% so a majority of the
users are men but still you have a lot
of women involved in on LinkedIn so a
nice you know nice mix between both
genders 38% of the user base are
Millennials you know a lot of young
people older people a nice mix from a
business of different business segments
different levels of business different
business industries and verticals are on
LinkedIn so don't be you know shying
away from
LinkedIn if your demographic or target
audience tends to be older just because
38% are Millennials doesn't mean
anything it means that everybody's using
it it just that means that hey you know
more than one-third of the users are
Millennials are younger now LinkedIn is
a b2b platform so if you're in the
business of generating business leads
then LinkedIn is the place for you to go
there's opportunities for you to
advertise on LinkedIn okay there's also
opportunities for you to post lots of
different content on LinkedIn so content
that works on LinkedIn can be a blog it
could be you know particular news
article
you know tips and best practices I've
posted videos on LinkedIn you know it's
good for jobs you said a lot of content
on LinkedIn so please take a sneak peek
at LinkedIn if I just go to LinkedIn
here you know and I just go to my home
the start news page you know I could see
the types of content that's been posted
so somebody just posted something with
an image you know then you got an
article down here okay you got you know
an influencer like Richard Branson
posting so you got a lot of different
types of posts that you'll be able to
see and you know leverage if you want to
meaning when I say leverage you see
somebody like Richard Branson posting
something hey stay fit and healthy you
know that's an image that's something
about not about business per se but you
know something interesting and unique so
you can see all sorts of different types
of content based on who you're following
on LinkedIn and who you're connected to
some things about LinkedIn you always
want to create an engaging profile when
I say engaging
first things first make sure it's
complete I mean there's lots of
opportunities so if you sneak over to my
profile here you want to be able to post
a lot of information about yourself so
about what you're affiliated with what
jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to you know complete your
total profile you can create a company
page for your business so if we go back
to LinkedIn we can just do a search for
simply learned and let's take a look at
you know their business page so if I
just do a search for simply learn here
so I select their page you can see just
like your profile page if you have a
business page set up on LinkedIn you
want to make sure it's complete you want
to put information about the company
what jobs are available and you want
your company to associate with that
business page anybody who does you know
follow that particular business page
part of the organization is gonna be
listed under people so and you want to
be able to post just like on your
personal profile if you have a business
page you want to be able to post unique
content I mean you can see here simply
learn is posting you know some of the
accolades that they have but they're
taking that a step further they're also
posting you know information about you
know upcoming events and webinars so
they're posting a mix of different
content and that's ideally what you want
to do on any social media platform is
mix it up and just like you can on
Facebook just like you can on Instagram
you can you know boost a post per say
okay so you can get that post in front
of some additional eyeballs now of
course you want to optimize your company
page for searches so it really does come
down to how many people are following
you but when you say when we say
optimize your company page just make
sure it's complete with some compelling
content and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about LinkedIn that I like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if I go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know LinkedIn
does give you opportunities to connect
with people okay so if I go to you if
you go to your profile you'll be able to
see other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them pay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so LinkedIn does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page
making sure both your personal and the
company page have all the content
necessary have all of it completed and
then increasing followers posting unique
content I mean that's really the key to
LinkedIn now again with LinkedIn you can
use different media you can use videos
SlideShare presentation images and you
can boost content as I mentioned before
you can boost content on LinkedIn so if
you want to get that content in front of
eyeballs you can do that so let's take a
look at an example of a campaign and
what you could do on LinkedIn in terms
of sponsored content so if you go to
LinkedIn's campaign manager I mean you
have an opportunity put your ad in front
of a particular audience
so really depends again on who you're
trying to target just like Facebook
which slants more towards personal
LinkedIn is gonna slant more towards
business so with LinkedIn you have an
opportunity to target a particular
industry a particular company a
particular job title okay so you could
target everything business-related on
LinkedIn so you can go ahead and create
an ad the ads have imagery to support
the ad and so basically when you set up
your ad you set up your target you could
choose your placement you're gonna be
able to see you know who it is you're
actually targeting and you can go ahead
and great thing about LinkedIn is you
have different ad formats and again you
can get really creative with who you
want to target and just like Facebook
you know LinkedIn has you know some
metrics that you can measure and figure
out how your particular campaign
performed by impressions buy click click
the array even conversions cost per
conversions and how many leads so
LinkedIn has built in platform for
measuring campaign success and so the
differentiation between Facebook and
LinkedIn is really this is the type of
demographics that you have to choose
from you know with LinkedIn you do have
you know different options available
based on business like your job title or
job level or industry or vertical so you
have a lot of examples available or a
lot of options available to you on
LinkedIn
in terms of advertising okay let's talk
about YouTube now so YouTube has 1.9
billion active users if it was a search
engine it'd be the second most popular
search engine the highest number of
monthly active users in decreasing order
starts at the United States Brazil
Russia Japan and India all big markets
all like to use YouTube but YouTube's
popular across the world just like
Facebook where the app is popular the
app on for YouTube is very popular so
70% of all views are generated from
mobile so with YouTube being a video
platform you definitely need videos now
there's a lot of industries on YouTube a
lot of industries in some of the most
successful brands on YouTube you know
range from logo to coca-cola you know
pretty much to every brand if you're a
brand you want to be on YouTube because
of the massive reach that YouTube has to
offer
coupled with video and how great video
is in terms of engagement it's a just a
great combination okay so some best
practices here for YouTube you want to
optimize your video for SEO to get views
and so we have a video that we've
created at simply learn how to rank
YouTube videos so if you watch that
video you'll get some really good tips
and strategies about how to you know
optimize your video for youtube
the very least you want to make sure
that you're using right the right
keywords and the title description and
hashtags so that's a start when we talk
about optimizing your videos want to
upload regularly and fix the schedule
for your videos because if you're
starting to get followers on YouTube or
subscribers they're gonna expect you to
produce more video especially if you're
producing engaging unique relevant
content for that target audience so
we're not saying you have to have a
video once a day or once a week start
small and build up and get on a regular
schedule and then you can organize your
videos in a playlist so you know if we
look at simply learn you
simply learn does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go simply
learns a YouTube channel and you can see
how it's broken down into playlists now
YouTube also has the ability because it
is global you do have the ability to
provide translations so if your target
audience is from another country it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea like
Facebook and Instagram or like LinkedIn
you can advertise on YouTube you would
just need to do that through Google Ads
so with Google Ads you're gonna say
Google I want to advertise and YouTube
and you have plenty of available options
to available to you anything from you
know pre-roll to showing up in the
middle of a video to showing up you know
before or excuse me at the end of a
video all the way to native content
marketing where you know your ad is
showing up next to a video so you've
plenty of options for advertising on
YouTube and then just like an Instagram
there are our influencers on YouTube you
know feel free to reach out to these
influencers and see if you can
collaborate in some way where maybe you
post their video on your channel they
post your video on their channel and
vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about Twitter now so with Twitter is a
micro blogging platform and so when I
say micro blogging I mean limited in
characters limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular
it has 326 million active users per
month and it does tend to slant a lot
towards Millennials it's a lot of young
people use Twitter and a lot of people
use it to get their news so no longer
are the days of grabbing that newspaper
no longer the days of going maybe to a
media news site online you can quickly
go to Twitter and get all your news
right there in a feed an easy feed let's
take a peek at Twitter here you know I
can get everything from you know
somebody posting something specific
about their dog you know all the way to
a particular job you know all the way to
industry news
you know all the way to basically an
advertisement all the way to a specific
news article so it's all here on Twitter
in your feed so Twitter does offer
videos so videos do work well so if I go
back here you can see you know here's a
video of Antonio Brown he's posting a
video of his news conference and another
promotional video so industries that
capitalize on Twitter as you can guess
if a lot of people go there from their
news you probably see a lot of news and
media and entertainment on Twitter so
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
can't use Twitter for your brand it
really comes down to target audience
some of the most influential brands are
slanted more towards you know news and
media but you know you got cosmetics you
got gaming companies you're gonna
everybody's on Twitter okay it just
comes down to does this platform have
your target audience and given the
nature Twitter you know how can you get
your particular brand product or service
out there in so many character okay some
other advantages and best practices you
can use on Twitter so I would recommend
implementing Twitter cards and really
all Twitter cards does is allow you to
attach rich photos or videos and
different media experiences to tweets so
when you can attach you know rich media
like videos and images to tweets it can
help drive traffic and engagement to
your website all it's gonna take is just
a few lines of markup to your web page
and then users who tweet links to your
content will have a quote unquote card
add it to the tweet that's visible to
their followers so that's how it works
I would certainly look to get Twitter
cards implemented if you are going to
use Twitter as your platform of choice
for social media marketing so it does
enhance the experience for the end user
and because allows you as an advertiser
or as somebody leveraging social media
to really enhance your tweet and it just
provides a better experience for the end
user who's looking at your tweet and so
like LinkedIn you can really take a look
at who's trending what's trending on
so Twitter makes it easy for you to you
know follow so here they'll list of who
to follow
so these who to follow are similar to
what you've been posting or similar to
your industry and then here you can look
at trends you can look at what hashtags
are trending and so if you click on a
particular hashtag you can you know
follow a particular you know person who
or organization who tweeted something so
you always are reminded in Twitter who
to follow and so it makes it easier for
you to pick and choose who to follow and
build up your following fairly quickly
because Twitter actually provides you
with opportunities on who to follow just
like LinkedIn just like YouTube just
like Instagram there are influencers out
there people who have a large number of
followers who tweet on a regular basis
who tweet original content who get high
engagement these are influencers and
these are the people you want to engage
with so look for those people on Twitter
follow them I mean the rule of thumb is
if you follow someone on Twitter you
know generally they're gonna follow you
back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on Twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on Twitter you can you
promote your tweet just like you promote
a post on Facebook or Instagram or
LinkedIn but more so I think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
I always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again Twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that Tash tag as
well you can have multiple hashtags in a
particular tweet and so don't be afraid
to use the unique hashtag
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your tweet to
get noticed and then you can use tweet
chat or some there's some other tools
out there that are available to allow
you to find people to follow and these
people might be interested in your
product or service because you know they
can fit your target audience or you can
connect with like-minded folks who are
in the same industry or have similar
products or interests so tweet shots
available for that reason and you want
to take advantage of these tools because
again with Twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following that is going to engage with
your tweets so let's talk about what
tools are available for social media
marketing so when we talk about all
these platforms available to us okay we
talk about Facebook and Instagram and we
talked about LinkedIn and Twitter and
YouTube I mean those are popular
platforms but at the beginning of the
session I mentioned there's hundreds of
social media platforms out there and if
you're posting content on a number of
them you want to be able to organize
that content you want to be able to
organize it and schedule it you know
where it makes sense and when it makes
sense you want to stay organized and so
there are tools available to help you
stay organized tools like HootSuite
buffer or sprout social okay some of
these tools are available you know at a
cost of a free trial or at a low cost
per month so regardless of whether
you're using a free version of one of
these tools or another tool mint listed
or you're actually paying for it it's
worth the investment if you're going to
partake and social media marketing and
even if you're on one platform it's
still worth it to have a social media
tool available to help you schedule and
not only do these social media tools
help you schedule they do a lot of other
things too for example they help you
measure the engagement of your posts so
let's say example of one of them like
sprout social so if I go to sprout
social
here I can see for a particular company
I'm able to see you know how my post and
get we're engaged okay so I could see
daily engagements on particular
platforms I can also you know schedule
my
post so I can go ahead and pick a time
and date to schedule them and so I can
go ahead and post something and put it
in a queue to be published for example
tomorrow or next week or whatever the
case may be
so these tools do a lot for you I mean
they help you discover new followers
they give you in-depth reports they help
you stay organized and so to me it's
worth the investment to look at one of
the tools listed here you know these are
some of the more popular ones - maybe
even a free version but regardless of
how much you pay and what tool you're
using it's still worth the investment
just to make sure you're scheduling your
post at the appropriate time so you're
not posting something back-to-back as an
example and you're able to measure
accordingly so it's nice to be able to
go into a tool like sprout social go to
reports and measure you know in one
place you know how Twitter is performing
or how Facebook is performing or how
LinkedIn is performing and so that's
what's a lot of these tools provide is
nice reporting options and nice
scheduling options so you can find more
content you can create by using these
tools again you can schedule efficiently
analyze them and you can use insights to
improve your campaign so why these tools
give you nice insights to how the post
was actually engaged and you want to be
able to leverage that and some of these
tools if not all of them have social
listening and social listening is
monitoring what's being posted out there
so what else is posted you can take a
look at and if it's something
interesting or relevant you can go ahead
and follow or take part in that
conversation okay so that's what social
listening allows you to do and a lot of
these platforms have that as a feature
so let's take a look at tips to be a
good social media marketer so some of
the important things you should take
care of our set up a social media
marketing plan when I say set up a
social media marketing plan there's some
questions you want to be able to ask
okay what platforms am I gonna use
what's my objective on each platform in
fact before you choose the platform you
want to figure out what your objective
is in terms of social media so
your objective could be different on
each platform it could be brand
awareness on Facebook and it could be
promoting a particular product on
Twitter your objective is gonna be on
each platform you want to be able to
choose your KPIs and align your KPIs
with each platform meaning what metrics
are important to your business goals and
you want to be able to figure out okay
what kind of content am I going to post
on these social media platforms so you
want to get organized and put a plan in
place and then you want to create
informative shareable actionable and
relevant content and what I mean by all
that is you want to create unique
content that doesn't mean you can't
leverage what other people are doing
meaning you know if I'm you know in the
shoe business
I can certainly go to Nike or adidas or
puma or Reebok and see what kind of
posts they're putting out and then I
could take their cue and do something
similar but I want it to be unique to me
and I want it to be unique to my brand
and I want to be able to keep my content
visual meaning I want to be able to use
as many photos and videos as I can
that's available to me because remember
videos generate better engagement I want
to be active and responsive with my
customer base meaning the whole point of
social media is to engage and people are
going to respond they're gonna comment
they're going to take part in what you
post and so whatever they do you want to
be able to respond accordingly whether
that's positive or negative and then you
want to measure metrics like conversion
rates and click the rate so that goes
back to putting a plan in place figure
out what your metrics are and then when
you're posting on a particular platform
you want to be able to lean on those
metrics to make sure you're achieving
your goals so you want to have those
metrics in place beforehand and then you
want to be able to use those metrics
moving forward as you post the whole
idea is if you're measuring what you
post you're obviously gonna want to lean
more towards what's working versus
what's not working so if you have any
insights or comments feel free to post
them below this video in the comments
section
we'd love to hear from you or your spawn
accordingly I want to thank you for
paying attention and hanging in
and hopefully you were able to get
something out of today's seminar if you
have any questions or need more
information please feel free to go to
simply learn comm thank you hi there if
you liked this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos de nerd up
and get certified click here